- Maybe toss an egg in there for protein.
- Maybe, that actually
would be pretty good.
- Maybe, we don't know.
- Okay, gettin' fancy on me.
(laughing)
- I'm a very fancy person.
- As am I.
- So.
(laughing)
(light upbeat music)
- What's up guys, I'm Inga.
I grew up in Hong Kong
and I love instant ramen.
I know most people think
instant ramen's more like
a broke college student's
breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
But come on guys, there
are so many more amazing
instant ramen brands out
there that people need to try.
So I went to Chinatown found a
couple of my favorite brands,
brought them back to the office
to show my coworkers a whole new world.
(upbeat jazzy music)
(cash register bell)
- This looks legit, and...
- It smells really good.
- It smells legit.
- Uh...
- Yeah that's Shin smell.
- It's reminiscent of
instant ramen but better.
- It's a little spicier
than I was expecting.
- Yeah. It's nice.
- Which is a pleasant surprise.
- Lot's of flavor. Salty. Spicy.
- Spicy.
- The broth really tastes like
the broth you get at the restaurant
when you go get fancy ramen.
- I'm like probably gonna
finish this if that's okay.
(laughter)
- Now I'm excited for the next one.
- Yeah.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- Ooh!
- Whoa!
- This is nice!
- The oil on this!
- Yeah!
- It looks fancier than
the one that we just had.
- It smells almost like, creamier maybe.
- Is it Uni? Truffle?
- Powdered milk?
- I'm trying so hard to place it.
- I feel like there's coconut in this.
- Definitely something
from the ocean is in here.
- It's the perfect amount of like salty...
- Yeah.
- Spicy, and creamy.
- I like milk but only
in coffee or cereal.
Not necessarily when it's
mixed in with other stuff.
- I'm surprised this is instant.
- This is my new favorite.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- This one looks like artisanal.
- This smells incredible.
- It smells expensive.
(cash register bell)
- It is so beautiful.
- No broth.
- Yeah no broth.
- I've never had mayo on noodles before.
- Oh! Yum!
- It's good.
- The flavors are really crazy,
and they're like kind of
baked into the noodles.
- The mayo's so interesting.
I don't know if I would've picked it,
but now I'm eating it I'm like into it.
- I would never have assumed
it came from a dried form.
- I'm like super into this.
This tastes really good to me.
- This is very delicious.
- It's pretty restaurant quality.
- This actually tastes
like restaurant quality.
- If it's like a rainy
day and I'm in my P.J.'s.
Like, I would snack on this.
- Yeah.
- Clearly.
(bowls clattering)
- Yeah. Totally good.
- Yeah. Really clean.
(upbeat techno music)
- I thought I knew all
kinds of instant ramen,
but today my mind was blown
because there were some different flavors.
- Not only is like, the
quality can be better,
but also like there's
so much different types
and interpretations. It's pretty cool.
- They really defied my expectations
in terms of what the
gourmet landscape was like.
- I've seen the other
side. I cannot go back.
- I feel like we went on a journey.
- Yeah. We traveled.
- You're a changed man.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Today changed me.
- That flavor and the water as well.
I mean, the broth, as well. Sorry.
For calling it water.
(upbeat techno music)